okay so Lukas numbers a named after guy
could Edward Lukas although he was
French so new car but I'm going to say
Lucas because I am lazy and if it wasn't
for Lucca Lucas we wouldn't really care
about Fibonacci because Fibonacci did
some things he wrote those numbers down
didn't generalize them didn't analyze
them he did introduce some interesting
you know number systems to Europe and
did some other cool bits and pieces but
these were more of a footnote to the
story of his life and then Luca went
hate these are really interesting and
he's the guy who promoted them and he
went with his own sequence which is
better than the Fibonacci numbers and
you think working if if malechy starts
1:1 was our next option so Fibonacci
starts 1:1 and then it goes two and then
three and then five and then eight and a
13 and then onwards
well what if we start assessing 1:1 what
if you start one two we cannot start one
two because we're just starting here it
will all we've done is move along
slightly and so we're going to get the
same numbers if we start one two Lucas
numbers you start to one so you just
swap them around and then you repeat
exactly the same pattern so two plus one
then gives us three and then we get four
and then you get server then you get 11
and 18 and these are the Lucas numbers
and to my mind this sequence of numbers
is far more interesting than the
Fibonacci sequence of numbers and these
have a stronger link to the golden ratio
so if you take the golden ratio fight
which is really because one point six
one eight zero three three nine eight
another nine so on okay right so we know
for any of these sequences they're going
to approach that ratio but what if we
start with the ratio well if we want to
take the ratio and then get a sequence
of numbers so if you calculate Phi
squared Phi squared equals two point six
one eight zero so on which if you round
to the nearest whole number is three so
approximately
okay so I'm going to this column is
rounding to nearest whole number if you
do Phi Q by cubed equals four point two
three six zero six so on which if you
ran that nearest whole number is four
five to the four is six point eight five
for10 so on down to the nearest whole
number seven pi to the five and if I
carry on and take each of these and
around them to the nearest whole number
what do I get
sure enough these are the Lucas numbers
appearing up here and that will carry on
all the way down every power of the
golden ratio
we Anders the nearest whole number gives
you the Lucas numbers and so that's not
the fact that the Fibonacci numbers are
linked to the golden ratio in a way that
every other similar sequence is if you
start with the golden ratio and then
take powers is because of what you're
doing is you're multiplying each term by
the Gordan by that ratio to get the next
term which is that wonderful property of
our own bangs on about but this is these
are the numbers it generates if you
start with that and then go to the
sequence and that's why I think the
Lucas numbers are vastly superior I've
been very careful I've never said Lucas
sequence which is a very good point
because Lucas sequence is well it's a
family of other things so Lucas did some
amazing research into all the weird
properties you get from some of these
various sequences and this these numbers
were just one specific example of a
Lucas sequence but they're the most
common one and the most famous one which
is one thing called the Lucas numbers
but there are all sorts of amazing
things you can do with these numbers you
can air everything from obviously
wonderful ratios but you can use them to
test if a number is prime and I mean
there's a whole amazing area of math
look up Lucas sequences there's an
incredible stuff in there one thing
about this that strikes me though is
like we often talk about how mathematics
is very precise and perfect in this
great thing this sequence does does
match but it only matches by kind of
roughly rounding and it seems like each
time it kind of slightly misses the
target but it misses by such a small
amount that it doesn't matter this
doesn't seem very much like a lot of
other a lot of the other mathematics I
see it seems kind of a bit fuzzy and
almost II
I think rounding people you know rain
hate on rounding can I think that's what
you do at a primary school and if it
will view it as mass you did very early
on and very simple and that there's a
kind of a pulse like people linked
mathematics with unnecessary precision
and they link mathematics with doing
things that are pointless and
over-the-top and so for some reason one
of the first things people will do in
their learning math at high school no
one looks smart is write down
unnecessary number of decimal places
right because I think what's more
masking them all the more numbers you
write down here the more mass we're
doing and I think it's a shame there's
some amazing things that drop out of
rounding and so I think it's nice that
the Lukas numbers you do get these
wonderfully precise answers are the
powers are you round with the nearest
whole number and that's where the beauty
is I like that
eight thousand two hundred and twenty
nine plus seventeen thousand three
hundred and ninety nine equals forty
five thousand six hundred and twenty
else I'll do it for a few of these and
you can dip through obviously so this is
the brady sitting one thousand two -
this is the brady sequence so these are
we're going to call these the brady
numbers